[Musique]
l'horloge de big ben qui retentit
comme une piqûre de rappel les
britanniques ouvre une nouvelle page de
leur histoire en 2021 leur excite sujets
brûlants de ces dernières heures mais le
maire de londres a tenu à rappeler
mercredi soir les fondamentaux nous
avons constaté une augmentation massive
du nombre de personnes qui ont attrapé
ce virus ces derniers jours et semaines
le national health service nhs aux
hôpitaux à londres ont plus de passion
aujourd'hui qu'à tout autre moment de
cette pandémie et c'est pourquoi nous
tenons tant insisté sur le message
vraiment important que tout le monde
doit rester à la maison
un message à l'encontre du gouvernement
du premier ministre boris johnson ce
dernier plus optimistes pour la nouvelle
année lunaire le bab nous savons qu un
dur combat nous attend encore pendant
des semaines et des mois car nous sommes
confrontés à un nouveau variant de la
maladie qui exigent une nouvelle
vigilance
mais alors que le soleil se lève demain
en 2021
nous avons la certitude de disposer de
ces vaccins mis au point dans un royaume
uni qui est également libre de faire les
choses différemment
et si nécessaire mieux que nos amis de
l'union européenne de la france et des
yeux
les regards se tournent vers la
grande-bretagne première nation à avoir
administré un vaccin contre le coc vie
19 celui les laboratoires
américano-allemand files heures bio
ntech l'eau royaume-uni sixième pays le
plus touché au monde deuxième pays
européen après l'italie avec plus de 70
mille morts et selon plusieurs experts
outre manche le royaume peut s'attendre
au pire ils nouvelle souche du virus a
déjà entraîné une augmentation de 40%
des cas contaminés
en une semaine les scénarios
d'intervention le plus strict avec des
mesures de confinement dans toute
l'angleterre et les écoles fermées en
janvier ainsi que 2 millions d'individus
vaccinés par semaine est le seul
scénario que nous estimons pouvoir
abaisser le pic de charge des unités de
soins intensifs sous les niveaux aperçu
durant la première vague
bonne nouvelle pour le gouvernement de
boris johnson l' agence britannique du
médicament a autorisé la mise en
circulation d'un nouveau vaccin
fierté nationale celui du groupe
britannique astrazeneca
il sera utilisé dès le 4 janvier 100
millions de doses ont été commandées
une gestion de l'épidémie vivement
critiqué aujourd'hui par l'opposition la
possibilité de regrouper trois foyers
différents pour la période de noël ou
encore la récente campagne de
communication au sujet des vaccins
pointé du doigt le premier ministre doit
être beaucoup plus proactive face à la
désinformation dangereuse diffusées par
le mouvement antivaccin ses bêtises nous
met tous en danger
la nouvelle souche a en fait été détecté
pour la première fois en septembre
les signaux d'alarmé ont retenti pendant
des semaines mais le premier ministre a
choisi de les ignorer cette semaine
nouvelle annoncée mesures renforcées de
nombreuses régions du centre du sud et
du nord de l'angleterre passe au niveau
d' alerte 4 avec l'ouverture seulement
des commerces de première nécessité les
écoles secondaires pourraient retarder
échelonné leur réouverture après les
vacances de noël pour permettre la mise
en oeuvre des tests
certaines écoles primaires des zones les
plus touchées sont aussi concernés